Do you think abortion restrictions won't affect you?
I mean, not an egg,
but I'm not the one getting pregnant.
Okay, but
if the women you're hooking up with
can't access abortion and contraception,
you think they're gonna be as carefree about casual sex?
But they're still contraception.
Project 2025 would restrict access to birth control and Plan B.
No plan B. Yep.
You better get used to a lot more responsibility.
I mean, do you ever think about whether you can afford child support
when you hook up with a girl?
No. And guys can't sleep with women.
They'll just do it themselves.
Oh, yeah, no,
forget about corn. They're banning that, too.
No corn. Yes.
Project 2025 wants to jail only fan creators and porn stars.
That's a little bit of a Cork block.
And think of the cultural shift.
I mean, Project 2025 also wants to ban sex education.
So you'll have a whole generation of people
who have no idea what they're doing in bed.
Okay, it's kind of making it sound like
people aren't going to be getting laid anymore.
I'm just saying it's gonna be a lot harder. No pun intended.